and then the hope is that
the robots the ai systems might be able
to care that
carry the the
fire of consciousness or whatever makes
us humans yeah
like a little drop of whatever makes us
human so special not to be too poetic
about it but no but i
i like being poetic about it because
it's a it's an amazing question you know
is there something beyond just the bits
the ones and zeros to us
you know it's an interesting question um
i like to think that there there isn't
anything
and that how beautiful it is that our
thoughts our emotions our feelings our
compassion
all come from these ones and zeros right
that to me actually is a
a beautiful thought and the idea that
machines
silicon based life effectively could be
our natural evolutionary descendants not
from a dna perspective but
they are our creations and they then
carry on
yeah that to me is a beautiful thought
in some ways but others find it to be a
horrific
thought so that's exciting to you it is
exciting to me as well
yeah because that to me from a purely
engineering perspective it's i believe
it's impossible to create
like whatever systems we create that
take over the world
it's impossible for me to imagine that
those systems will not
carry some aspect of what makes humans
beautiful yeah
so like that a lot of people have these
kind of paper clip ideas that
we'll bring we'll build machines that
are cold inside or
philosophers call them zombies they're
that naturally the systems that will
out-compete
us on this earth will be cold and
non non-conscious not capable of
all the human emotions and empathy and
compassion and love
and hate ever the the beautiful uh
mix of uh what makes us human but to me
intelligence requires all of that so in
order to
out-compete humans you better be good at
the full picture right so artificial
general intelligence in my view
encompasses a lot of these attributes
that you just talked about yeah
curiosity yeah inquisitiveness you know
right
it might look very different than us
humans but it will have some of the
magic
but it'll but it'll also be much more
able to
survive the onslaught of existential
threats that
either we bring upon ourselves or don't
anticipate here
on earth or that occasionally come from
beyond and there's nothing much we can
do about a supernova explosion that just
suddenly
you know goes off and
you